[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau data nous
interdire les deux tiers des électeurs
ne se sont pas déplacés lors des deux
tours des élections régionales et
départementales
tout le monde cherche des raisons à ce
pic d'actes anti sionisme mais personne
ne se demande pourquoi un tiers des
français votent encore ce sont eux
pourtant qu'il devrait être l'objet de
notre curiosité ce sont eux qui sont
largement minoritaires eux qui sont
atypiques voire carrément exotiques
si un tiers des français ont fait
l'effort d'aller voter alors qu'ils
auraient pu faire autre chose il y à
bien une raison
il doit même y en avoir plusieurs mais
lesquels pour en débattre nous avons
invité thomas guénolé vous êtes
politologue professeur d'université vous
êtes l'auteur du livre les jeunes de
banlieue mangent-ils les enfants ou du
livre noir de la mondialisation qui est
paru l'année dernière chez plon vous
avez été membre de la france a soumises
qui est même qu'aux responsables de son
école de formation
mais vous avez quitté ce parti avec
pertes et fracas au bout de deux ans
alors pourquoi d'après vous un tiers des
français votre pied encore pour
plusieurs raisons qui sont cumulables
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils y croient voter
est un acte de foi dans la démocratie
représentative après tout pour élire des
représentants par habitude
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on fait par
habitude sans même y réfléchir et donc
quand on a l'habitude de voter ben on va
voter par éducation aussi il ya un
certain nombre d'entre nous dans les
parents leur ont tellement répété qu' on
doit aller voter qui le font par piété
filiale je vais dire est donc pour
toutes ces raisons là j'insiste sur le
fait qu'il y en a qui vote parce que
c'est un parce qu'ils y croient tiens il
ya une dimension d'acte de foi je le
disais et c'est particulièrement vrai
pour le vrai pour la présidentielle
c'est à dire plus que est d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus mais vraiment beaucoup
plus 80% de participation à une
présidentielle
la dernière de 2017 est donc quelque
part si on y réfléchit élire un
président de la république finalement
c'est un père noël pour adultes tous les
cinq ans il arrive avec voilà tout ce
que je vais faire pour vous vous votez
pour lui et comme le père noël n'existe
pas dans les cinq ans qui viennent on
est invariablement ensuite déçu mais à
mon avis c'est pour tous et pour ce
qu'elle est il de scop de raison que les
gens votent abel françois vous êtes
professeur d'économie à l'université de
lille vous avez beaucoup travaillé sur
le coup du vote mais aussi sur le
bénéfice que l'on peut en tirer la
satisfaction qu'il y a voté ce que cela
apporte alors en deux mots n'en parlera
plus longuement pourquoi est-ce qu'on
vote d'après vous
bah pour les raisons pour des tickets
parce que pour certaines personnes le
coût du vote est plus faible parce que
pour eux le vote est plus important et
puis parce que on aime ça aussi
indépendamment du résultat du vote
on aime voter en tout cas les gens qui
vont voter aime ça nicolas froment vous
êtes sociologue et philosophe de
formation co rédacteur en chef du
magazine frustration vous êtes l'auteur
avec céline derkaoui de la guerre des
mots combattre le discours politico
médiatique est paru au passager
clandestin et il y a cinq ans vous avez
publié les citoyens ont de bonnes
raisons de ne pas aller voter
la maison d'édition c'était au bord de
l'eau alors pourquoi ils doivent avoir
aussi de bonnes raisons d'aller voter
pourquoi à votre avis eh bien vous avez
raison de poser la question en ces
termes vous l'avez dit les votants sont
devenus minoritaires et donc ça permet
effectivement ce côté cette question là
et je partage les raisons qui ont été
données par thomas guénolé abel françois
c'est à dire effectivement il ya une
grande part de croyants de croyance et
je dirais même d'adhésion c'est à dire
c'est une adhésion au régime républicain
on vote par principe on vote pour
montrer qu'on appartient ce régime là et
qu'on le respecte et on voit que c'est
une position de plus en plus minoritaire
et puis-je ajouter book et hop
l'intérêt que peuvent avoir un certain
nombre de groupes organisés intérêts qui
peut être finances qui peut être à
participer à ce jeu électoral là parce
que finalement les élections de plus en
plus pour la majorité des gens pour les
classes laborieuses
le résultat devient de plus en plus
toujours le même c'est à dire qu'on a
des politiques qui leur sont plutôt peu
favorable pour tout un tas de raisons
qui sont le cadre du libre échange le
cadre européen
mais par contre pour les cas supérieur
et ses différentes factions les
élections c'est un vrai moment
d'arbitrage entre leurs intérêts et
selon le candidat qu'elle soutienne il
peut y avoir des effets différents sur
les secteurs qui vont être soutenus et
donc c'est pour ça que le spectre des
votants se rétrécit petit à petit parce
que finalement ils concernent que les
gens qui ont vraiment intérêt qu'ils
vont vraiment voir leur vie ou leur
portefeuille changer en fonction du
résultat et la plupart des gens estiment
que ce n'est plus l'heure car alors on
va voir parce que le vote par intérêt
c'est effectivement une dimension très
importante qu'on va aborder dans ce
débat mais d'abord les politiques
iq les politiques ont-ils intérêt à ce
que plus d'un tiers des français aillent
voter ne paraît pas évident après tout
c'est plus facile de convaincre 15 % des
inscrits c'est ce qu'il a fallu à tous
ceux qui ont été élus ce week-end 15%
des inscrits que d'en convaincre 51% non
abel françois tout à fait en plus ça
coûte cher de convaincre les électeurs
d'aller voter de de se déplacer
d'accepter de couvrir le coût de
l'action de vote ça coûte cher pour les
partis politiques et les candidats donc
il ya assez peu d'incitations pour eux a
essayé de mobiliser l'électorat pour
accroître la participation d'autant que
les modalités aujourd'hui de financement
des partis politiques ne les incite pas
du tout à avoir une base importante une
base de partisans importante voulait
dire qu'on est remboursé de ses frais de
campagne en fonction des votes qu'on a
eu du pourcentage mais indépendamment du
nombre d'app stores de david
absentionnistes taxi qu' il n'y a que 5
% des français qui ont voté
on touche là même seube ou s'il y en
avait eu 50 % tout à fait à la fois les
candidats sont remboursés sur le même
montant mais les partis politiques
également tous les ans reçoivent des
subventions qui ne dépendront pas qu'ils
ne seront pas liés avec le taux de
participation aux élections législatives
oui on voit leur évoqué par exemple a
été réélu ce week-end avec très peu de
campagnes très peu de meetings
pratiquement rien quoi quand même je
pense que la classe politique j'entends
par là les politiciens professionnels
je pense qu'ils sont parfaitement quand
même conscient que ça met en danger
l'existence même de leur profession
d'avoir des taux de participation ou
plutôt des taux d'abstention
l'occurrence qui vont être à 40% 50% 60%
il commence à y avoir le feu
simplement parce que ça produit
immédiatement la manque
enfin une légitimité démocratique par
définition extrêmement faible j'ai
regardé avant de venir pour vous donner
une idée d'à quel point il ya un
problème maintenant le député de ma
circonscription là je dis moi je vais à
montreuil le député c'est alexis
corbière
il a été élu par moins d'un électeur sur
quatre c'est vraiment très peu l'extrême
droite a gagné les dernières élections
européennes en 2009 avec 11 % des
inscrits c'est ridicule en reine est ce
à dire que tous les autres en dessous
aux municipales à cannes en 2001 la
droite le maire sortant il a fait un
score de maréchal il a fait quasiment
90%
j'ai regardé mon pourcentage dans
inscrits ça fait 27 et là hier soir au
second tour des régionales le meilleur
score ces listes de carole delga en
occitanie elle a fait grosso modo 60 %
en vrai c'est 22 % des inscrits et donc
toutes les décisions prises par des
assemblées aussi mal élus ont
automatiquement une légitimité
démocratique extraordinairement faible
oui ça dépend selon g papa de l'égalité
ou de constitutionnalité son collègue
aux principes démocratiques la
légitimité totale pendant non non non
non vous ne faut pas confondre la
légitimité démocratique plus il ya de
participation plus elle est forte et la
légalité de votre mandat qui est
simplement vous avez respecté les règles
constitutionnelles nicolas fera mot sur
ce sujet problème ou pas problème c'est
que je pense que c'est un fait
à court terme ce n'est pas un problème
on le voit d'ailleurs les politiques
élus actuellement se félicitent de leur
élection s'auto congratule ils ont aucun
problème à se sentir élu légitimement
élu légalement élu ça crée pas beaucoup
de complexes
moi j'ai travaillé pendant un temps à
l'assemblée nationale donc avec des
députés qui sont globalement tous très
mal et lui puisque la participation à la
législative est très faible
thomas guénolé l'a bien montré je n'ai
croisé aucun député qui un jour m'a dit
le fait d'avoir été si mal et lui rend
mon action difficile et ça me perturbe
dans ma légitimité donc personnellement
ça n'a pas d'impact sur eux à court
terme par contre je pense que dans les
temps qu'on va on va avoir avec des gens
qui souhaitent prendre des décisions
qu'ils appellent le même difficile
impopulaire etc
je pense notamment la réforme des
retraites par exemple que emmanuel
macron 1 a remis sur le grill eh bien
ces gens là ont l'habitude de se
prévaloir de leur légitimité
démocratique et de dire je fais ce que
je veux parce que vous m'avez élu
sauf que ce discours il a de moins en
moins tenir la route de plus en plus on
va avoir des gens qui vont dire mais
attendez j'ai regardé votre taux réels
d'eads élections par rapport au nombre
d'inscrits et il est faible et même
macron finalement n'a pas été élu par
une majorité des gens est donc cette
légitimité lé petit à petit atteinte
et même si au moment de l'élection pour
les raisons légales convient d'évoquer
elle n'a pas d'impact sur le long terme
oui effectivement ça
peut menacer des institutions pour
autant moi je crois en leur solidité et
en leur capacité des politiques à croire
ce sont ceux qui croient le plus dans
les mythes républicain qui les servent
donc ça va pas les ébranler de sitôt
malheureusement moi je vous ai dit que à
chaque fois qu on nous annonce le score
de l'abstention et qu'il est
impressionnant les politiques sa digne
et s'auto flagelle mais si ça les embête
est vraiment il suffirait de rendre le
vote obligatoire au rire ni ils ne le
font pas alors pourquoi ne le font-ils
pas être que ce serait une bonne idée de
rendre le vote obligatoire abel françois
alors il ya des arguments pour il ya des
arguments contre et très honnêtement les
arguments contre ont plutôt tendance à
surpasser les les arguments positifs
d'un vote obligatoire
le premier des éléments c'est que ça
rognent encore plus la légitimité des
aigus que une abstention très faible et
encore quand on n'a pas envie de parler
d'abstention on n'a pas pris en compte
le fait que beaucoup de citoyens ne sont
pas inscrits sur les listes électorales
parce qu'avant de voter il ya un autre
coup à assumer pour les pour les
individus et les citoyens c'est le fait
d'aller s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales mais donc le fait que de
rendre le vote obligatoire ça donne pas
plus de légitimité aux élus ça accroît
en fait le vote le fait de ne pas aller
voter le coup de ne pas aller voter
ça rend pas pour autant le vote plus
intéressant donc il ya un risque quand
même assez important avec le vote
obligatoire d'amener à des comportements
en termes électoraux assez erratique
c'est à dire que grosso modo en force à
aller voter pour pas payer une amende
donc je vais voter un peu n'importe quoi
dans l'urne et puis un autre problème
aujourd'hui en france et que la gestion
des listes électorales pose beaucoup de
problèmes ça pose des problèmes aux
communes ça pose des problèmes à l'insee
qui a en partie récupéré la gestion de
ce grand listing des français est
aujourd'hui dans le cadre actuel et dans
les moyens qui sont mis à la disposition
de la gestion des listes électorales je
ne vois pas comment on pourrait mettre
en place un vote obligatoire obligatoire
vous tabac j'ai beaucoup écrit là-dessus
mais honnêtement maintenant j'en suis
plus au stade je le détaillerai
peut-être en deuxième partie d'émission
sur qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais
maintenant je suis plutôt favorable à ce
qu'on remplace les assemblées élues par
des assemblées intégralement tirés au
sort je ne détaille pas pour l'instant
je le ferai plus tôt en deuxième partie
parce que ça nécessite un développement
soit mai
sur les motifs parce que vous le disiez
tout à l'heure monsieur sur la question
de pourquoi on pourrait rendre le vote
obligatoire encore faut-il comprendre
pourquoi il ya une abstention aussi
élevée en particulier en particulier
dimanche soir j'ai regardé on a un
sondage au doxa auprès des
abstentionnistes régionale et donc le
sondage leur demande mais pourquoi vous
vous êtes abstenu
c'est intéressant voir les résultats il
se passe que beaucoup de gens disent les
abstentionnistes on dissocie ils pensent
cela etc
mais il se trouve que je suis aux
abstentionnistes ont envoyé un message
aux électeurs
c'est marrant c'est toujours le message
avec lequel le mec qui causent en leur
nom et d'efforts mais donc ceci pour
dire si on a regardé chiffres 16% des
abstentionnistes 10 je ne suis pas allé
voter parce que je n'ai pas reçu les
informations nécessaires ce qui rejoint
vos éléments d'analysé monsieur sur le
coup pour aller voter il ya le coup
d'information
41% des abstentionnistes 10 je n'étais
pas disponible ce qui est une manière
polie de dire qu'ils estimaient avoir
autre chose à que celui là s'est
prononcé sur le temps et de mots de
passe leur goût donc ce n'est toujours
pas un geste politique c'est en fait je
m'en fous voyez où j'ai mieux à faire
oui c'est ça comparativement et donc par
rapport à tout ce que je pourrais faire
ça je m'en fous et donc un
abstentionniste sur deux aux régionales
ce n'était pas un geste politique donc
primo si vous enlevez cette moitié là
vous retombez sur une abstention normal
pour des régionales en réalité moyenne
et l'a donc le geste politique est à un
niveau normal d'abstention à l'heure
actuelle et ça veut dire aussi que
toutes les analyses que qu'on a pu
entendre sur le fait que ce serait la
montée en puissance d'une grande grève
civique
en fait non cette analyse là d'après les
données qu'on a un là les fausses c'est
à dire que ça existe l'autre moitié des
abstentionnistes quand on leur demande
c'est un geste politique le disais dans
le dans le sondage que je cite c'est un
rejet du système ou 8 j'ai pas confiance
etc
mais c'est à peu près la moitié un peu
plus un peu moins ça dépend des fois et
en fait c'est stable et donc si je
résume pardon d'être nu mais ça me
paraît important pour qu'on voit les
choses précisément en fait aux élections
vous avez 50 % des français qui
correspondent aux classes que vous
citiez tout à l'heure monsieur fera bon
vous avez à peu près 50% des français
qui croient aux élections qui votent
tout le temps et qui sont politisées
tout le temps vous avez 30 % qui n'y
croit pas mais qui bizarrement vote à la
présidentielle ce qui fait que ça monte
à 80 % de participation
et puis vous avez 20 %
ils sont inscrits sur les listes
électorales mais qui ne va jamais voilà
donc si on regarde en fait c'est ça qui
se passe et quand on fait un tableau
complet et en plus il ya tous ceux qui
ne sont pas inscrits sur les listes
électorales on y reviendra nicolas fera
mon toit le vote obligatoire
oui moi évidemment le vote obligatoire
je pense à ce serait une énorme une
énorme bêtise et je pense qu'on a on est
dans un pays où on met suffisamment
d'amande aux gens sans avoir à rajouter
parce qu ils ne daignent pas aller voter
le vote obligatoire en fait il
présuppose que des raisons de
l'abstention sont mauvaises qu'elles
sont visuelles
quels sont à de la flemme ou de lundi et
moi j'ai tendance à penser qu'il faut
pas faire de tri peut si vous voulez et
le geste politique politisé d'abstention
l'abstention à part d où la question
avec la critique explicite je pense
qu'effectivement il ya des
abstentionnistes très militant comme tel
mais y'a des gens qui n'y vont pas par
indifférence qui dit je m'en fous et
pourra je vois pas pourquoi on y est le
type de lait faudrait faire ce tri parce
qu'en réalité l'indifférence face aux
élections elle a des origines politiques
et à l'être les effets politiques qui
est ce niveau d'abstention est l'origine
politique c'est de se dire c'est quoi
l'enjeu c'est quoi l'enjeu et s'attend
que nos institutions seront pas capables
de répondre à cette question
eh bien ça ne servira à rien et le vote
obligatoire pour forcer les choses or
c'est quoi l'enjeu
à la question est tout à fait légitime
et on voit bien quand vous regardez la
participation aux différentes élections
que c'est bien en fonction en juin les
gens votent non sur les régionales ce
qui vous comparer les différentes
régions on voit bien qu'il ya des
régions la participation était beaucoup
plus forte qu'en les régionales est
chargée de beaucoup plus de contenu
politique
c'est le cas de la corse et le côtes de
la guyane réunion notamment remontée des
taux de participation était beaucoup
plus important contre bien quand même
que en fonction d'enjeux on se mobilise
plus tout comme les gens se mobilisent
plus pour la présidentielle parce qu'ils
savent que si les choses peuvent un
petit peu changé malgré tout c'est quand
même plus à la présidentielle que
l'élection législative qui suit ou de
toute façon vous avez avoir députés qui
confondent la hapa de la parade de la
figuration parce que c'est vraiment le
cas quand un gouvernement peut faire un
amendement qui lui doit pas plus c'est
bien que le sétif en france ne sert pas
à grand chose
vous voyez cette indifférence il faut la
questionner et elle est à trouver du
côté des instituts
on est pas de la façon de forcer les
gens à s'intéresser à quelque chose dont
ils ont raison ils ont raison de ne pas
s'y intéresser
abel françois rey pour que ce soit clair
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer le
coup enfin le calcul du vote plus
exactement comme disent les économistes
et donc le coût du vote qu'est ce que
c'est que le coût du vote et a converti
les bénéfices qu'on peut en retirer et
notamment là on parlera des enjeux
effectivement qui ont leur apparente ans
et même du vote par intérêt parce que la
réussite dans les enjeux il ya l'intérêt
qu'on peut avoir un tel résultat
d'élections mais d'abord le coût du vote
se déplacer et s'informer le coût du
voit qu'il est il a deux de grandes
composantes la première c'est ce que ce
dont vous parliez c'est l'information
c'est ce que ce qui a été citée par
monsieur guénolé cette question de
monsieur n'est pas suffisant et
suffisamment d'informations pour pouvoir
me déplacer pour voter aux régionales ou
départementales
c'est le coup en fait de préparation de
son action boîte c'est dire que le temps
qu'on va prendre le temps que les
électeurs prennent pour construire leur
choix c'est à dire qu'ils vont consacrer
des minutes à lire les programmes à
s'intéresser à savoir qui est candidat
sur quel sur quel programme
quel positionnement etc or le souci
c'est que c'est tenir informés de
l'activité électorale d'activités
politiques en général ça prend beaucoup
de temps et ce temps ben on va
l'utiliser dans cette activité là mais
au détriment d'autres choses détriment
de son travail détriment de chercher un
travail au détriment de sa vie familiale
de loisirs et c'est donc lui il ya un
coût d'opportunité très important à
construire sont ses choix de gratter
donc au final à se décider d'aller voter
ou pas et puis l'alsacien belle françois
juste sur ce point parce que ça explique
pourquoi on vote plus à la
présidentielle qu'aux régionales à la
présidentielle on en entend parler
depuis tellement longtemps
on connaît les candidats donc au fond
s'informer on sa forme sans s'en
apercevoir
alors que sur sur la sur la rn les
régionales la plupart des candidats on
ne les connaît pas
et ont donc on est sa forme et prend
beaucoup plus de temps
et au fait en voyant les résultats on
s'aperçoit qu'ils ont été réélus les
sortants donc en fait on est allés voter
parce qu'on était sûr de son candidat
parce que peut-être parce qu'on veut
toujours la même chose soit toujours
socialiste toujours à droite et auquel
cas d'ailleurs ce sont les deux partis
qui ont remporté ces élections comme par
hasard et et et on part tout faux je
sais j'ai perdu le fil de ma pensée je
vous redonne la parole et mais voilà
c'est sa forme et ça ça prend du temps
d'autant plus de temps qu'on ne sait pas
pourquoi ces élections sont faites et 10
avec ti wii est normalement c'est le
rôle de la campagne électorale d'avoir
cette cet échange d'information alors
qu'il va bien sûr des candidats des
partis vers les électeurs mais aussi les
électeurs comme candide en allant à la
rencontre des électeurs reçoivent aussi
une information sur et bien le
positionnement des acteurs qui
souhaiteraient et c'est notamment pour
les élections locales
et c'est vrai que là la campagne était
plutôt peu suivie peu animé alors il
faut pas acheter donc lui totalement la
pierre aux candidats et aux partis à
l'heure je disais qu'il n'avait peu
d'incitations mobilisés ils ont aussi à
notre souci c'est que en termes de
propagande et de deux techniques
marketing qui est à leur disposition
la réglementation est extrêmement
restrictifs pour surtout en temps de
pandémie ou en fait on a des campagnes
électorales qui sont construites sur un
schéma thénia ou du 19e siècle où en
gros à faire un meeting dans un préau
d'école et c'est comme ça qu'on va
mobiliser les gens or aujourd'hui pour
intéresser les gens et donc pour
produire de l'information pour avoir
leur attention
mais il faudrait mettre en oeuvre
peut-être des techniques de propagande
plus plus habituel en tout cas plus
diriger vers un électorat qui est large
qui a un peu de temps à consacrer à ses
activités politiques et électorales et
donc il faudrait peut-être aussi revoir
ces éléments là juste pour finir le
deuxième élément en fait de le deuxième
composante c'est le fait de se déplacer
le jour du vote parce que là aussi il ya
un coût d'opportunité c'est ce que
disaient les gens disant mais moi j'ai
autre chose à faire
s'ils ont autre chose à faire ça veut
dire que pour eux en fait le coup
d'aller voter le coup de prendre une
heure pour sortir de chez soi et aller
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'isoloir 5 ou alors
comme en france et le dimanche c'est
plutôt un coût qui est pris sur les
activités
de loisirs ou une activité familiale
mais c'est aussi un coup et on a un
grand nombre d'études qui montrent que
ce coût de déplacement à qu'on peut
mesurer en km ou par les tickets de bus
par exemple ça pèse sur la participation
donc on a ces deux composantes qui
forment le coût qui est un élément très
important dans la prise de décision
d'aller participer
on le voit d'ailleurs que ça pourrait
être aussi vraie passion pour les
électeurs mais aussi pour les médias
on peut remarquer par exemple que en ce
qui concerne les élections
départementales les médias ont quasiment
fait l'impasse dire que je vais montrer
la carte des résultats des élections
départementales
vous n'avez pas vu à la télé cette carte
est ce que les journalistes en fait il
faudrait ça leur coûte de s'informer sur
les élections départementales de savoir
ce qu'il joue de savoir c'est quoi le
pouvoir du département qui a gagné qui a
perdu et au fond ce coup ils ne veulent
pas l'assumer et est donc vous ne savez
pas qui a gagné les élections
départementales tous les médias s'en
sont foutus bah voilà les résultats et
vous les verra pas de sitôt à la télé
très loin si je peux me permettre c'est
c'est un peu le problème de l'oeuf et la
poule c'est à dire que le sens dans
lequel ça ce fait n'est pas forcément
évident ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'à mon avis le comment dire les médias
de masse audiovisuel ne parle des
élections qu'à proportion de l'audience
que ça peut faire dans le public dans un
paysage concurrentiel où ils sont là
c'est pas un secret et c'est totalement
normal dans ce dans le système actuel
ils sont là pour faire de l'audience et
donc si en tant que média vous consacrer
un temps d'antenne assez conséquent a
parlé de choses dont beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de gens se foutent
vous allez perdre de l'audience c'est
aussi simple que ça je vous rappelle que
il ya un million de français qui ont
voté à l'élection de miss france ou en
termes de centres d'intérêt et donc ceci
pour 17 pas beaucoup c'est pas c'est
quand même pas mal en fait
alors qu'on n'en parle jamais sauf en
soir c'est quand même remarquable et
donc ceci pour dire plus
au-delà de l'anecdote mais simplement je
regardais chiffrant en arrivant et ça me
paraissent un peu étonnant mais ceci
pour dire que les médias nous parlent de
la présidentielle parce que quand ils en
parlent ça fait de l'audience c'est que
quand ils font des débats télé entre les
candidats à la présidentielle ça fait de
l'audience et donc ça permet d'avoir à
mesure de l'audience des recettes
publicitaires c'est ça le modèle
économique d'un média et c'est pareil
pour la presse papier c'est pareil pour
la radio etc etc et donc
il ne parle quasiment pas des
départementales parce qu'en réalité nous
en tant que public consommateur de leur
offre médiatique on s'en fout on est
trop nombreux à s'en pour les
régionales
et si vous aussi des régionales est
quand même parler des réveils cependant
très peu parlé en réalité et quand il en
parle je m'en rends compte quand on
m'interroge pour le en tant qu'analyste
politique ou commentateurs
éditorialistes pour le pour les
régionales on m'a posé surtout des
conseils des questions sur les
conséquences possibles des régionales en
vue de la présidentielle
et on m'a quasiment pas pareil de poser
poser de questions les journalistes sur
les régionales pourquoi il s'intéresse
directement sur le méné sur les
régionales n'ont plus que jamais sur les
régionales on m'a posé des questions
mais c'était quel impact généralement
c'était quel impact sur la
présidentielle les candidats doivent
savoir c'est parce que ça fait pas
d'audience moi c'est pas moi c'est
presque un coût pour les journalistes de
s'intéresser aux départementales comme
original d'abord est trop beau mais
s'ils s'attendent et suivez le
raisonnement juste que je voudrais vous
en convaincre et à travers vous notre
public et si ça faisait de l'audience
d'hier au moins un média qui s'en serait
rendu compte en ayant fait un sujet un
micro sujet dessus à partir du moment où
vous voyez que ça fait de l'audience
même si c'est épouvantablement chez ans
de préparer le sujet vous allez le faire
vous allez faire une meilleure audience
que votre concurrent en tant que média
c'est donc pour moi la preuve que c'est
le public qui s'en fout c'est pas les
médias qui veulent pas en parler il se
ils ont réussi à faire de l'audience
avec sur une départementale c'est celle
où il y avait une candidate voilée
là il ya eu quand même un peu de temps
le détournement des minutes avant la
pause
nicolas ramond oui c'est important ce
que vous dites sur les médias moi ce que
j'ai pu constater c'est que je lis
beaucoup la presse locale ou régionale
en fait les moyens de cette presse-là
ont drastiquement baissé dire qu'il ya
de moins en moins de journalistes
spécialisés il ya de moins en moins de
journalistes tout court d'ailleurs
et finalement l'actualité politique
locale n'est plus du tout commenté
et ça c'est une première chose donc qui
pour moi résulte de choix effectivement
sans doute basé sur une audience ou sur
des prétentions économiques eux des
actionnaires mais il ya autre chose
c'est que il ya beaucoup moins d'intérêt
de toute façon à suivre ce qui se passe
dans les églises les exécutifs et les
parlements locaux municipaux etc
parce que l'action s'il ya énormément
technocrates ise c'est à dire que de
plus en plus on nous fait passer ce
qu'ils étaient avant des débats
politiques sur que faire que faire de
notre commune que faire de notre région
que faire de notre département est aussi
que faire de notre pays d'ailleurs pour
finalement un débat technique qui est
quelle est la bonne réforme à mettre en
oeuvre pour mettre en place ce bon plan
d'économies qui nous a été dicté par les
bonnes instance technocratique elle même
inspirée par le sz un présage de
bruxelles et donc finalement le suspense
le suspense a raconté l'intérêt a
raconté cette histoire là il a
complètement disparu parce
qu'effectivement il n'y a plus aucune
surprise ces décisions sont souvent
connues d'avancé
et d'ailleurs les élus s'en remettent
eux mêmes à des supras entité que ce
soit les intercommunalités par exemple
ou tout un tas de comités techniques à
qui on délègue finalement les décisions
démocratiques
donc la démocratie c'est intéressant
c'est palpitant c'est bien raconté non
encore faut-il qui en est une
et actuellement il y en a pas vraiment
c'est pour ça que les journalistes comme
tout le monde d'ailleurs essayé de
chercher de l'intérêt dans ces
régionales de façon beaucoup plus
indirectes c'est-à-dire quel impact pour
le futur et là je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est à dire qu'on va éviter ces
régionales n'ont été traitées que sous
l'angle de quel impact pour la
présidentielle qui reste en fait est de
plus en plus le scrutin qui peut
vraiment en tout cas dont on a
l'impression que ça peut vraiment tout
changer parce que là effectivement il ya
de grandes orientations politiques qui
s'affrontent mais sur les
départementales sur les régionales
qu'elles étaient les grandes
orientations politiques qui
s'affronteraient quels étaient les
grands projets on ne sait pas peut-être
si on n'avait pas vous poser la question
des enjeux c'est justement la question
qu'on va se poser juste après une pause
[Musique]
assiste-t-on à une soviétisation de
l'économie c'est simplement une place de
plus en plus prépondérante de l'état
aujourd'hui avec les prêts garantis par
l'état et que fait l'état se paye les
entreprises l'état pourrait devenir un
partenaire un actionnaire d'outré un
très grand nombre d'entreprises
françaises
on est un peu dans une logique
d'économie de guerre où l'état a suppléé
on va dire à la défaillance du privé on
est dans quelque chose qui ressemble à
une soviétisation il est vrai que le
gouvernement n'avait aujourd'hui pas
d'autre moyen que de faire le point
qu'il en coûte
l'état aujourd'hui aide tout et
n'importe quoi et c'est bien le problème
qui va soutenir va pas va subir ça c'est
nous dans nos impôts
au carrefour d'une pollution insultes et
d'une nécessité technologique absolue
les terres rares sont au coeur des défis
du 21e si c'est un enjeu stratégique
pour tous les prix puisque leur accès
est aujourd'hui principalement chinois
en l'état actuel des capacités minières
connu la part chinoise et réserve
mondiale est de l'ordre de 37 % dans la
cadre de la guerre commerciale avec les
états unis la chine utilise sa position
comme levier de négociations mais il est
clair qu'avec les pénuries et les
tensions que nous allons connaître sur
certaines terreur il faut envisager
d'autres solutions
[Musique]
pourquoi un tiers des français votre
t-il encore on reprend ce débat avec
thomas gwénolé qui est politologue
l'auteur du livre noir de la
mondialisation avec l'économiste
abel françois et avec nicolas ramond qui
est sociologue et philosophe et qui a
publié la guerre des mots avec céline
derkaoui alors les enjeux on vote par
intérêt alors je pense que ça rentre
dans le calcul du vote si chère à un
économiste comme abel françois parce que
vous l'avez dit ça nous coûte d'aller
voter ça nous coûte de nous informer
mais ça peut aussi nous rapporter voté
par intérêt à vos yeux n'a rien de
déshonorant c'est tout à fait humain
en revanche nicolas fram on disait tout
à l'heure que ceux qui ont intérêt à
voter ce sont les classes possédantes
les classes bourgeoises
est ce que c'est le cas après tout les
agriculteurs dépendent des subventions
les les fonctionnaires dépendent du
budget les médecins des bandes des
remboursements de la sécurité sociale
tous ces gens là ont intérêt parfois
leurs revenus leur patrimoine dépens de
des résultats électoraux
oui c'est ce qu'ont ceux qu'on appelait
tout à l'heure les enjeux c'est à dire
que pour chaque individu les enjeux sont
différents et les enjeux en fait sont
liés avec la décision publique
est ce qu'on voit c'est que plus le
revenu de la personne ou plus les
revenus du patrimoine la valeur du
patrimoine de la personne sont
dépendantes de la décision publique
et puis ces personnes là on rend
l'intérêt à participer au wac pourquoi
parce que pour eux il ya un vrai enjeu
derrière l'élection
donc c'est le cas des agriculteurs dont
une grande partie aujourd'hui du revenu
dépend d'une décision publique
c'est le cas aussi des propriétaires
immobiliers c'est à dire que les gens
qui possèdent leur maison par exemple
partie si beaucoup plus aux élections le
locales aux élections municipales
pourquoi parce que la valeur de leur
patrimoine chez leurs leur maison ou
leur appartement dépend pour beaucoup de
ce qui va être décidé dans le plan local
d'urbanisme par exemple donc quand on
prend comme ça toutes les grandes
catégories socio-démographiques de
personnes on se rend compte que celles
dont les revenus et le patrimoine des
pans de la décision publique vont
beaucoup plus voter donc c'est le cas
des fonctionnaires
tout à fait et des retraités aussi des
retraités des professeurs des médecins
ne confondra décidèrent oui
effectivement c'est important de parler
de cette question d'intérêt ça ça va un
peu à l'encontre du mythe républicain
selon lequel dans l'isoloir on vote dans
notre âme et conscience pour des grandes
idées et des grands principes mais la
réalité est tout autre et abel françois
vient de le montrer
je pense aussi que ça explique
évidemment une grande partie
d'abstention parce que les catégories
qui ont été mentionnés bas ne sont pas
ne représente pas toute sa société et il
ya des gens comment comment dire pour
moi il ya des gens qui seront toujours
plus ou moins gagnant des élections
et puis y en a d'autres qui seront
toujours perdants et qui leur semble de
plus en plus il ya une scène qui m'a
frappé cette semaine c'était des
ouvriers 2d fonderie de bretagne qui est
un sous traitant notamment de
l'industrie automobile qui ont brûlé
tous ensemble leur carte d'électeur dans
un brasero en disant voilà on en veut
plus on en fera plus jamais parce que de
toute façon ça ne change rien et on n'a
plus du tout confiance dans cet état là
à chaque fois de toute façon c'est les
gens comme nous qui sont à voir et cette
scène elle et elle est particulièrement
violente elle a été peu commenté
mais en même temps elle en dit long ça
veut dire qu'il ya des gens pour qui de
toute façon les élections la
participation au régime républicain
c'est un jeu à somme nulle parce que le
contexte idéologique a évolué de telle
façon que de toute façon il n'ya plus
d'issue autre que la fuite en avant vers
toujours plus de délocalisations
toujours plus de libre-échange toujours
plus de poids pour des entités
supranationale et finalement il ya plus
de vrais de vrais enjeux pour les
classes ouvrières les classes
laborieuses à voter qui n'a pas toujours
été le cas puisque pendant tout un temps
il y avait des relais politiques
électoraux fort ça a mis du temps à
s'établir mais ça s'est établi au cours
du deuxième siècle puis ça s'est
déployée au cours du 20e siècle c'est à
dire qu'on avait des partis politiques
qui représentait différentes tendances
de représentation de la classe ouvrière
la classe employés de la classe salariés
en général et ses relais politiques là
ont peu à peu disparu et d'ailleurs ont
peu à peu lâché la classe ouvrière très
explicitement pour être beaucoup plus
intégrée au jeu républicain est pour
beaucoup plus préserver leurs intérêts
d'élus leur intérêt d'élus locaux de
notables de potentats ils se sont
intégrés au jeu républicain mais n'y ont
aimé mais à côté de ça la classe
ouvrière est la classe laborieuse sens
et d intégrer et ça c'est très important
de se dire qui a intérêt au vote
qui a intérêt à ce qui devenu comme je
disais un arbitrage entre différentes
catégories de la population mais
supérieure eh bien ce n'est pas tout le
monde et plus la société est
inégalitaire et plus elle et elle est
injuste et va dans le sens de l'intérêt
des des plus des plus riches finalement
parce que c'est à ça qu'on assiste est
bien plus les gens s'abstiendront mais
ça semble tout à fait logique tant qu'il
n'y aura pas d'autres issues d'autres
alternatives qui leur seront proposés
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une autre raison
que vous développez dans le coup du vote
abel françois c'est de dire qu'au fond
pour les plus éduquées et ça prend moins
de temps de s'informer sur les élections
donc ils veulent davantage et a
contrario les classes ouvrières par
exemple qui ont besoin de plus de temps
parce qu'ils ont moins de connaissances
acquises tout simplement sur ce sujet
évidemment ils seront moins tentés de
voter parce que ça leur prendra plus de
temps et on en revient toujours au cou
du vote tout à fait parce que en fait
dans le coup de l'information il ya le
coût de collecter l'information pour
savoir qui sont les candidats leur
programme leur part leur parti leur
affiliation idéologique etc
et puis aussi un coup parce qu'il faut
du temps pour traiter cette information
là et les personnes les musées du quai
pour eux ce coût de traitement est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus court sans
traitement est beaucoup plus court donc
par par conséquence le coût du voide
pour eux est beaucoup plus faible et
donc effectivement les taux de
participation sont beaucoup plus élevés
parmi les populations les plus éduquées
que parmi les autres mais ce qu'il
faudrait juste revenir un instant sur le
sur la question des enjeux c'est le fait
que une fois qu'on a pris en compte ses
intérêts et c'est à dire que je ça que
chacun sache c'est où se situe son
intérêt il va le comparer par rapport à
ce qui est offert par les candidats ce
qui est promis par les candidats et là
il ya deux positions possibles c'est
soit j'arrive à détecter quel est le
candidat qui correspondrait le mieux
à mes intérêts ou en tout cas ce que ce
mois je souhaiterais comme politiques
publiques soit il ya d'autres
possibilités la possibilité que je
n'arrive pas à différencier les
candidats entre eux parce qu'ils sont
trop technocratique par exemple parce
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui une partie de la
politique s'est transformé en la gestion
publique très technique et donc j'arrive
plus à distinguer la droite de la gauche
pour aller vite ou le centre y compris
et puis il ya un autre phénomène c'est
que moi par rapport à ce que je pourrais
souhaiter peut-être que ce qui est
offert par les candidats événements
beaucoup trop loin de moi
et dans ce cas là je peux m'abstenir
parce qu'on appelle la négation
c'est à dire que ce qui m'est offert me
déplaît est vraiment trop éloignés par
rapport à moi mes préférences et moi ce
que je souhaiterais en termes de
politiques publiques et c'est pour ça
que ça ne compensera pas le coût du brut
et c'est pour ça que je n'irai pas voter
je voudrais d'abord dire que je pense
pas que lier un lien entre la montée des
inégalités la montée de l'abstention
je renvoie ce que je disais en première
partie d'émission sur les différents
motifs d'abstention qui montre la montée
supplémentaire d'abstention en
particulier aux dernières régionales ne
s'explique pas par un geste politique
par ailleurs tout simplement dans les
années 60 les inégalités économiques et
sociales étaient en réalité plus élevé
qu'aujourd'hui
et pourtant la participation électorale
était bien supérieure à ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
y compris aux élections intermédiaires
et donc je pense que l'explication par
la montée des inégalités ne se vérifie
pas par les chiffres que nous avons les
chiffres aux élections je dis ça c'est
une première remarque deuxième remarque
il ya par rapport à la notion de coût
d'information qui est beaucoup puisqu'il
est très central dans les centrales dans
les différents éléments dont on vient
discuter
je voudrais souligner qu' il ya
énormément de gens et à mon avis ils
sont majoritaires parmi les votes
exprimés pour lesquels le coup
d'information et de zéro parce qu'il ne
s'informent pas parce qu'ils votent
toujours la même chose oui et je
voudrais vraiment qu'on souligne ça
c'est à dire qu'en fait les changements
de vote sont minoritaires dans
l'électorat et que la majorité
l'électorat vote encore et toujours la
même chose et donc c'est dans les années
60 justement parce qu'on votait pour le
parti communiste ou voter pour le parti
socialiste 70 ans comme étaient ouvriers
parce qu'en plus il comme il n'arrivait
pas au pouvoir on n'avait pas de raison
de changer son pote mais c'est encore
les attitudes majoritaire parmi les
votes exprimés
même si le vote automatique donc le vote
toujours dans le même camp baisse au fil
des années ça c'est une tendance lourde
lectorat il est de plus en plus
le terme technique c'est la volatilité
électorale mais tout simplement ça veut
dire que l'allégeance au parti comme à
tous les corps constitués et tous les
corps intermédiaires est en baisse au
fur et à mesure que l'électorat se
renouvellent générationnel mans ce qui
est une manière polie de dire que les
plus fidèles à des partis politiques
moeurs progressivement et sera remplacé
par des jeunes générations qui ne le
sont pas ça c'est simplement à mon avis
un élément principal d'explication
d'accord avec cette cette explication
abel françois oui oui mais le le
problème de du changement progressif
sociodémographiques c'est que il permet
pas en fait d'expliquer les variations
qu'on peut observer d'une élection à
l'autre pourquoi parce que ces
mouvements sociaux démographiques sont
très lents dans le temps parce que ça
prend beaucoup de temps que qu'une basse
en fait de population change en termes
sociologiques ça prend énormément de
temps
or on voit qu'il ya des vases des
variations très importantes d'une
élection enveloppe de la participation
et des choix de vote
donc il faut aller chercher sur d'autres
facteurs explicatifs dans les
comportements d'une élection après
l'autre parce qu'il ya des effets
contextuel bien évidemment pas ce qu'ils
disent effets dangereux parce qu'elle
disait fait d'informations tour de
l'élection le dit tout à l'heure la
présidentielle c'est de l'élection reine
en france donc on a une production
d'informations et donc un effet de
mobilisation de l'électorat autour de
7,2 cette élection qui est phénoménal
donc il faut faire il faut faire
attention que l'explication sociologique
donne bien en fait le fond si vous
voulez comme un fonds de d'explication
c'est la variable lourdin explicative
mais que pour comprendre les effectue à
sion d'une élection à l'autre et il faut
revenir sur des éléments de calcul
enfin des éléments plus individuel même
si les facteurs sociaux sociologique
peuvent influencer c'est la manière dont
les gens réalisent leurs calculs du vote
ça c'est évident au hocine beaucoup
l'élection présidentielle de 1974 entre
valéry giscard d'estaing et françois
mitterrand comme un exemple même parce
que c'est là je crois où l'abstention a
été la plus faible
on peut aussi l'expliquer justement par
l'importance de l'enjeu on avait c'est
on aller voter on devait choisir entre
le jour et la nuit
selon de le bord que l'on était c'est à
dire que la gauche l'arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir de françois mitterrand
et de la gauche au pouvoir
c'était changer la vie
pour ceux qui étaient favorables et
c'était voter pour l'arrivée des chars
soviétiques sur la place de la concorde
pour ceux qui étaient défavorables on
comprend bien qu avec un tel enjeu la
mobilisation soit très importante
si l'enjeu est aussi clivant et
peut-être que ça explique pourquoi pas
lors de ces élections régionales
on a tellement parlé de sécurité alors
que ça n'était pas un enjeu des
élections régionales
on parle de sécurité parce que c'est
qu'ils vivent et que donc ça évite de
beaucoup renseigné les électeurs sur
ceux sur les sur les sur ses intentions
il suffit de dire je suis pour la
sécurité je suis pour qu'il y ait plus
de police et hop on a on a envoyé un
signal qui permet à l'électeur de nous
identifier éventuellement de voter pour
nicolas fera mon oui c'est très
important ce que vous dites sur cette
élection présidentielle effectivement
d'un côté on avait un candidat qui avait
une volonté affichée de rompre avec le
capitalisme ce qui est quand même un
sacré changement de paradigme et un
autre candidat beaucoup plus
conservateur est beaucoup plus favorable
à l'économie capitaliste telle qu'elle
était donc là on a vraiment un choc et
on a vraiment on est à la croisée des
chemins et cette croisée des chemins
j'ai envie de dire on la connaît plus
depuis au moins 1980 2,83 c'est à dire
le tournant de la rigueur le moment où
tout le parti socialiste se convertit à
l'économie capitaliste est dit que
maintenant il suffit de faire des
aménagements à l'intérieur et se faisant
d'ailleurs participe lui-même du
chapitre de dérégulation de la finance
et de l'espace de libre échange et à
partir de là le champ des possibles
s'est considérablement réduit et donc
périodiquement les candidats se rendent
bien compte de ce champ des possibles
réduit étant de le réouvrir autour de
nouveaux débats de nouveaux clivages
sont jamais évidemment abordé qui vaches
politiques et économiques que peu
d'entre eux va l'affronter
par contre le clivage de la sécurité qui
n'en est pas vraiment parce que dans le
fond au nom des d'accord pour dire que
la sécurité c'est important qu'il faut
donner plus d'argent aux forces de
l'ordre et qu'il faut que chacun se
sente protégé chez soi une fois qu'on a
dit ça il ya plus vraiment d'enjeu je
voudrais revenir sur la question du
décryptage qui va pour moi avec cette
question de l'enjeu c'est très important
effectivement il ya des gens qui
arrivent très bien a décrypté sous tech
ne comprennent même pas quel est le
parti politique associé
autre acte qui est en face d'eux et ça
c'est très important j'ai vu les travaux
d'un vin sociologue de l'abstention
jérémy moualek qui disait que lors de la
dernière élection il avait compilé
l'ensemble du matériel de campagne et
qui avait plus de 85% de du matériel
qu'ils avaient analysé qui ne comportait
ni logo de parti ni de quoi que ce soit
c'est à dire qu'en fait il ya une
désidéologisation progressive du monde
politique ou simplement les arguments de
campagne ne sont plus voté pour moi pour
telle orientation politique tel héritage
historique tout ce que vous voulez mais
votez pour moi parce que je suis un bon
gestionnaire parce que je suis quelqu'un
de bien parce que j'emploie les bons
mots etc etc
et donc si vous voulez là le problème du
décryptage se rejoint le problème de
l'enjeu c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens
qui ont une capacité à décrypter
parce que sans doute qu'ils connaissent
intel ils connaissent tel candidat aux
élections départementales
ils connaissent tel candidat aux
élections original donc voilà le monde
des notables voit très bien de quoi il
s'agit quelles sont leurs différences
quels secteurs ils vont éventuellement
favorisés quelle est leur paradigme de
gestion des politiques publiques et
peuvent éprouver de la sympathie pour
eux mais le commun des mortels lui tout
se ressemble ces tracts se ressemblent
énormément c'est matériel de campagne
sur son énorme aimant les mots clés sont
à peu près les mêmes on a toute une
novlangue politique qui apparut et qui
n'est plus idéologique en fait qui est
idéologique précisément parce que
derrière elle porte bien un programme
mais qui n'est plus porteuse de clivages
politiques et donc il est tout à fait
logique
nicolas fera non pardon de vous
interrompre mais il ya encore des
parties aujourd'hui sur le marché
électoral qui qui préconise des ruptures
le la france a soumises et et pas c'est
pas le parti communiste français des
années 60 70
mais il est résolument anticapitaliste
si on veut si on est anticapitaliste on
a un candidat on a des listes qui sont
anti capitaliste et le rassemblement
national aujourd'hui trust une bonne
partie du vote des classes populaires
notamment des classes ouvrières
or il n'est pas anti capitaliste mais il
annonce lui aussi une rupture
or le la france a soumise ne percevons
pas dans les intentions de vote et le
rassemblement national là a perdu un
paquet de points par rapport aux
dernières régionales donc ça veut dire
qu'il mobilise aussi peu que les autres
ou en tout cas de moins en moins comme
les autres en dépit d'une idée
isation très forte pour moi là il s'agit
vraiment de l'argument central c'est à
dire effectivement les parties de
rupture n'attire pas seulement la
question c'est sont ils encore des
parties de rupture on voit que le front
national c'est beaucoup à ça j'ai sur
son passage y sur son discours socio
économique
on ne parle plus de sortie de l'euro on
parle plus vraiment de sortie de l'union
européenne et on parle même de
rembourser la dette publique donc
là-dessus marine le pen et ses
lieutenants ce soir aligné sur la doxa
dominante en la matière on n'est pas
dans un programme de rupture
et quant à la france un smith voilà
c'est beaucoup plus complexe à la france
insoumise change régulièrement
d'orientation n'a pas de ligne
directrice très clair sur les échelons
locaux et en particulier régionaux et
les programmes régionaux de france a
soumis ce n'était pas des programmes de
rupture avec le capitalisme ou l'ordre
l'ordre le public des collectivités
locales pas du tout et d'ailleurs il ya
une stratégie d'alliance assez claire de
la part de la france insoumise pour se
ranger du côté de la gauche
traditionnelle donc sur ces élections là
en tout cas la france insoumise n'était
pas dans une démarche de rupture et le
front national à mon avis est de moins
en moins d'une démarche de rupture pour
tous les gens qui veulent la rupture
que reste-t-il alors tabac guénolé mais
je vous êtes très respectueusement je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ça simplement
parce que je ne pense pas que ce soit je
les pensais par le passé je veux le dire
avec honnêteté mais je ne pense pas à la
réflexion que ce soit un problème
d'offre politique je pense sincèrement
que toute l'offre politique possible et
imaginable est sur la table est
facilement accessible pour l'élection
présidentielle
je précise on a déjà parlé des problèmes
aux élections intermédiaires ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que si vous
voulez une rupture avec le système
une vraie rupture quelle que soit sa
forme vous avez a priori un candidat
pour ça vous voulez sortir de l'union
européenne vous aviez asselineau qui
était candidat vous voulez la révolution
prolétarienne non seulement vous aviez
des candidats trotskistes mais vous en
aviez même jean-paul pluriel vous en
aviez deux vous voulez passer un système
qui soit globalement au sens
étymologique je suis pas dans le
jugement xénophobe
enfin c'est à dire d'extrême droite vous
avez une candidate pour ça vous voulez
que ce soit une rupture alors pas une
rupture systémique là je suis d'accord
avec vous mais une rupture au sens une
accélération une intensification massive
ya quelque chose qui serait plutôt du
thatchérisme
vous aviez françois fillon en fait etc
etc
jean luc mélenchon vous l'évoquiez tout
à l'heure c'était une candidature
indiscutablement socialiste à la
présidentielle et socialiste au sens au
sens 1980 maus ans adhérent du ps une
qui n'est plus d'ailleurs donc vous
aviez vraiment non seulement vous aviez
à peu près toute l'offre politique
imaginables sur la table mais en plus
l'envié des débats tv qui ont fait
d'ailleurs des très très bonne audience
pour la présidentielle avec des temps de
parole égouts et ensuite les gens sont
allés voter donc je ne pense pas que ce
soit un problème d'offre je pense
sincérement qu en fait
l'écrasante majorité de l'électorat
français ne souhaitent pas une rupture
est globalement satisfaite du système
comme il est je ne vois pas d'autre
conclusion possible parce que sinon en
l'état actuel de l'offre disponible
les gens ont les informations
suffisantes et les débats télévisés
disponibles avec les audiences qui nous
le prouve
en fait si les gens voulaient vraiment
massivement d'une rupture il voterait
pour le candidat de rupture qui je le
répète existe et donc ça veut juste dire
que l'écrasante majorité de la
population française est soit
conservatrice soit réformiste et que les
électeurs révolutionnaires sont
minoritaires dans ce pays par ailleurs
juste deux mots en deux mots je vais
dire en première partie que
j'expliquerai je voulais pas manquer ma
parole je pense vraiment de plus en plus
qu' il faudrait remplacer les assemblées
élues par des assemblées tirés au sort
pour le parlement pour les le conseil
régional pour le conseil départemental
pour le conseil municipal pour plusieurs
raisons mais déjà la raison de
représentativité une assemblée nationale
qui seraient intégralement tirés au sort
vous auriez 50 % de femmes vous auriez
6% de maghrébins vous auriez 7 % de
chômeurs qui serait député tire au sort
etc etc vous auriez une assemblée
véritablement représentative en plus des
représentants tirés au sort
ce sont des gens qui seraient des
véritables contre-pouvoirs alors qu'à
l'heure actuelle on l'a évoqué dans ce
débat les députés quand ils sont élus la
majorité a eu un comportement d'élus
godillots qui ne sont donc pas des
contre-pouvoirs vis-à-vis du
gouvernement la variété c'est une
réforme de ce système politique mais ça
ça encouragerais plutôt l'abstention
puisque nous demanderait même plus loin
il n'y a pas d'abstention puisqu'il n'ya
pas d'élection pour les assemblées ils
veulent pas des assemblées élues
les assemblées tirés au sort mais les
vêtements une menace aux réseaux je vous
le dis sincèrement
sachant que les élections d'assemblée on
l'a dit tout à l'heure systématiquement
n'intéresse pas les as et les électeurs
je ne connais pas d'autre façon
démocratique car le tirage au sort fait
partie de la démocratie je le répète
ou sur montesquieu démocratie athénienne
etc je ne connaisse pas d'autres façons
de produire des assemblées
démocratiquement légitime sans voter
puisque le vote ne permet pas de les
produire puisque trop de gens refusent
d'aller voter et qu'on a déjà dit que le
vote obligatoire était pas forcément une
bonne idée
donc à mon avis il faut tirer les
assemblées au sort c'est totalement
logique au fond il pour résumer on vote
quand on y croit quand on croit aux
conséquences de son vote quand on croit
au système quand on croit au pouvoir de
ce que l'on n'y lit quand on croit aux
enjeux on vote quand notre entourage
vote
notre famille le village quand on vit
dans un petit village on voit que vous
allez voter ou pas voter donc on va
voter
on vote quand notre milieu quand tu es
mobilisation il ya une mobilisation
collective autour de nous donc entre
notre milieu les gens avec qui on
travaille nos amis vote en étendant on a
tendance à voter mais c'est quoi le
problème au fond s'il n'y a pas plus
d'un tiers des français
il continue d'aller voter ce serait quoi
le problème
abel françois juste avant de vous
répondre
j'aimerais juste revenir sur la question
de l'offre et la quantité et la qualité
des candidats est en rapport avec la
participation c'est un vrai un vrai
problème c'est pourquoi parce que plus
vous multipliez le nombre de
candidatures plus les gens vont pouvoir
trouver en fait leur candidat préféré
celui qui est le plus proche de ce
qu'ils souhaiteraient mais d'un autre
côté vous ça demande beaucoup plus de
temps à être traités parce que ça
demande plus de temps en fait dans
s'informer sur le nombre de candidats
faire la différence que l'on disait
qu'il y avait au moins deux candidats
différents de l'extrême gauche aux
élections présidentielles en france
il faut quand même s'intéresser pour
savoir quelle est la différence exacte
entre ces deux candidats
donc d'un côté effectivement ça permet
d'avoir plus de plus de participation le
fait qu'on ait plus de candidats mais de
l'autre ça renforce en fait le coup de
s'informer sur sur la participation donc
ya pas un effet et univoque de la de
l'offre politique sur le sur la
participation et pour répondre juste à
votre question qu'est ce que ça fait ça
renvoie un problème de légitimité ça
c'est sûr de la décision publique mais
qui a été déjà un peu débattu dès le
départ et puis il faut se poser la
question parce que c'est grave mais ça
dépend en fait du contexte
ça dépend du niveau de socialisation du
niveau de collectivisation qu on a
collectivement décidé de mettre en place
dans notre économie dans notre société
et donc une économie qui est plus privé
c'est pas bien grave c'est moins grave
en tout cas de s'intéresser aux
élections que dans une économie comme en
france où on à 56 % de la richesse qui
tous les ans et décide et redistribuer
d'un point de vue collectif là l'enjeu
de l'intérêt de la chose publique est
beaucoup plus important que lorsque vous
habitez au mexique ou au brésil où la
dépense publique représente 20 à 30 % de
la richesse qui est créé dans l'année
les enjeux sont moindres donc c'est
beaucoup moins important et c'est vrai
que plus il ya de l'intervention
publique et notamment enfin que qu'elles
prennent la forme de d'une intervention
économique par une redistribution des
revenus ou que ce soit par de la
réglementation ou des lois qui sont de
plus en plus bavarde et qui rendent de
plus en plus dans le détail de la vie
des gens là effectivement la question
peut se poser deux est ce que finalement
qui est que 30% des gens qui élisent les
représentants qui vont décider de ce qui
va être fait en termes de réponse
sanitaire face à une épidémie
c'est peut-être plus un problème que si
on avait été 70 à 80 % à avoir participé
à l'élection de l'assemblée nationale
qui a voté les différents 3 face à
l'épidémie
nicolas fera bon je compléterai ce
raisonnement oui oui oui c'est
problématique si du moins on aime on
pense que c'est mieux vivre en
démocratie que dans un régime
oligarchique
pour toutes ces raisons qu'ils viennent
d'être cités et notamment le fait que
effectivement ce sera qu'une fraction de
la population qui va participer
dorénavant et pas n'importe quelle
fraction puisqu'on a vu qu'il y avait
des déterminants sociaux du vote qui ne
sont pas neutres en termes de classes
sociales
donc ça veut dire l'exclusion de plus en
plus fréquente de toute une portion de
la population et pas la plus riche et
donc du coup un renforcement encore plus
que ce qu'on connaît maintenant des
politiques publiques qui sont uniquement
orienté en fonction des intérêts des
croyances et des convictions d'une
partie de la population socialement
situer mais je voulais quand même
effectivement revenir sur cette question
de l'offre politique qui est tout à fait
central et je pense qui est quand même
le noeud du problème est là dessus on a
des analyses qui diverge moi je pense
que certes sur le papier il ya une offre
politique qu'on peut qualifier de
pléthorique
là on parle bien des présidentielles un
mois ce dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'était les régionales et là je pense
pas que l'offre politique soit très
variés mais par contre entre cette offre
politique théorique et autre chose qui
est cette offre l'offre politique
crédible bayard il ya un gouffre et
l'offre politique crédible c'est quelque
chose qui se construit c'est quelque
chose qui se construit médiatiquement
notamment est actuellement on est
absolument
chaque semaine on a droit à notre
nouveau sondage sur la présidentielle et
les sondages participe de cette de cette
crédibilisation de l'offre politique et
donc finalement au sein de cette offre
politique crédible on voit qu
actuellement par exemple le seul truc
qui ressort de ces différents sondages
qui par ailleurs sont menées dans des
conditions méthodologique très
insuffisante puisque ce sont des
sondages basé sur une élection où la
moitié des gens en fait ne savent pas ce
qu'ils vont voter pour l'instant est
bien en tout cas sa partie par un effet
performatif qui est de dire vous voyez
vous aurez à choisir entre ces deux là à
savoir maquereau et le pen par exemple
et donc ça décourage considérablement la
mobilisation parce qu'on se dit que tout
est joué d'avancé et finalement à quoi
bon se mobiliser à quoi bon
s'intéressait à une offre politique plus
restreinte puisque finalement l'offre
crédible qu'on nous amène l'offre crédit
pour nous montrent qu'on valorise
médiatiquement
celle qui a pignon sur rue celle qui
occupe les débats des plateaux télé baal
et l escalier est donc finalement
pourquoi perdre son temps à aller
s'intéresser aux autres puisque de toute
façon tout est déjoué d' avance et il
nous semble très improbable que ça se
passe autrement
et là l'effet des sondages pour moi il
est catastrophique les sondages ont un
effet démobilisateur
parce que les sondages resserre notre
champ des possibles ville thomas guénolé
oui je pense fin c'est même pas je pense
et nous avons collectivement les
chiffres sont disponibles que les
politiciens professionnels les français
n'ont pas confiance en eux mais les
sondages ne leur inspire pas confiance
non plus même si pour le coup leur
méthodologie en réalité généralement
sérieuse et jus des échantillons souvent
trop faible ça c'est vrai par pour des
questions de coût et les médias quand
ils nous disent machin crédible et
machin ne l'est pas ça a plutôt tendance
à faire monter machin qui est considéré
comme pas crédible tellement les médias
et en particulier les chaînes info etc
etc sont l'objet d'une méfiance massif
de la population mais donc d'un point de
vue pragmatique la présidentielle 80% de
participation il n'y a pas besoin de se
préoccuper ya pas de problème elle est
déjà très élevé et pour toutes les
autres élections qui sont des assemblées
élues
ben on est trop nombreux à ne pas s'y
intéresser donc il faudrait peut-être
les tirés au sort lieu les
on devrait avoir ainsi une vraie
diversité de milieu social de genre et
d'opinion dans toutes les assemblées du
pays merci tous les trois de voir
participer à ce débat merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré